if you're like most people you can
probably hold your breath 30 seconds
maybe a minute before you start to feel
the urge to breathe but the truth is
most healthy people can actually hold
their breath quite a bit longer than
that some people can hold it a lot
longer the current world record is 11
minutes 30 seconds and as if that
weren't ridiculous enough some
competitions allow athletes to breathe
pure oxygen before their breath bulbs in
Spanish free diver Elisha Goethe used
this technique to go 24 minutes and 3
seconds without breathing how is that
possible to find out I spoke with
professional free divers and researchers
who study their physiology I also took a
crash course in proper breath holding
technique when I started I could hold my
breath for about a minute but by the end
I was holding it way longer than I ever
would have expected but before we get to
that let's talk about some of the
science behind breath holding and why
the professionals are so much better at
it than the rest of us the reason why
some people are better at holding their
breath for a long time would be partly
genetics and partly because of training
that's Peter Lindholm he's a physician
researcher at Sweden's Karolinska
Institute he's been studying the
physiology of elite breath-hold divers
for more than two decades
he says that a lot of them are just
physically gifted take long sides for
example the average human has a total
lung capacity of between 4 & 6 liters
but many of the world's top free divers
have lung capacities of 10 litres or
more this isn't necessarily something
that they've trained they were just born
with big lungs on top of this many
professional free divers use the muscles
of their mouth and throat to overfill
their lungs with air this is called lung
packing and the x-ray footage you see
here shows an elite free diver using the
technique to expand his lungs several
leaders beyond their normal capacity
Lindholm also says a lot of elite breath
holders have relatively slow metabolisms
and relatively large blood ball
which makes sense your blood and your
lungs hold oxygen and your body consumes
it the slower you turn through your
oxygen supply the longer you can go
under breath full of air before
succumbing to unconsciousness but when
it comes to breath holding lung size is
only part of the equation even more
important is a physiological response
called the mammalian diving reflex when
you hold your breath it actually causes
your heart rate to slow down this
reduces your body's oxygen consumption
and what that does is it reduces the
blood flow to your legs and your arms so
blood is pumped preferentially to the
brain which means that the oxygen that's
in the blood and oxygen stores in the
lungs is used by the brain and not
consumed by your muscles and cold water
it actually amplifies the response
exposing your face to cold water
activates your tribe demonym nerves
what are your trigeminal nerves you take
your fingers and you pinch your cheek
and you feel it you have your trigeminal
nerves to think they're responsible for
sensation in your face but they also
connect to the part of your nervous
system that regulates your heart it's
not totally clear how or why this
response evolved and it's found in a lot
of animals but for some reason when your
tribe Emmental nerves get chilly
they tell your autonomic nervous system
to tell your heart to slow things down
and as it turns out slowing down is
probably the single most important thing
you can do when you're working with a
limited supply of oxygen I don't try to
focus too hard this is also a sport
where you can't really just push it like
you can you know get into a run and
really pump yourself and go do it
this is something to be completely the
opposite you have to be really really
relaxed Serbian free diver Lena Balta is
a 16 time national record holder she
showed us some of the techniques she
uses to calm herself before a dive the
most important is a series of slow
controlled inhalations called
a breather these help her relax and
purge her lungs of carbon dioxide
when she's ready to go she takes a
series of sharp inhales using the
muscles of her diaphragm to fill her
lungs before topping them off with some
lung packing these techniques take time
and practice to perfect which is
important because when done incorrectly
they can be pretty harmful or even
deadly purging too hard before a dive
can cause you to blackout which is not
something you want to do in the water
and it's exactly why divers not only
compete but practice in the company of
spotters and lung packing I can actually
tear the tissues in your lungs but
lindholm says that with just a few hours
of supervision and instruction most
people can actually learn to hold their
breath well over two minutes so I gave
it a shot Brian Stanley is a free diving
instructor at bamboo reef dive shop in
San Francisco he had me start by holding
my breath on land with my face in a bowl
of cold water I lasted about a minute
but thanks to the mammalian dive
response my heart rate dropped from 74
to feeling one next Brian had me moved
outside the pool deck to hold my breath
while lying down the idea here was to
help my body relax this time I held my
breath for just over 2 minutes next
Brian taught me some basic breath up
techniques to use my diaphragm to fill
my lungs and to focus on relaxing and
what this will do is it will help to
relax your muscles reduce any stress or
tension that you have in the body and
then get that heart rate lower which is
key for starting your free dive as I
held my breath he calmly instructed me
to relax every part of my body beginning
with my toes progressing up to my head
and then going back down to my feet if
you've ever taken a yoga class it felt
surprisingly similar to that before I
knew it I had held my breath for just
over 3 minutes
finally Brian had me put on a wetsuit
and get in the pool where we did some
more breathing exercises and finally had
me lie face down and hold my breath for
as long as possible now there's a few
things going on here
for starters being in the pool did a lot
to relieve tension throughout my body I
found it much easier to relax while
bobbing in the water than I did when I
was on the pool deck and the wetsuit
made me super buoyant which helped me
relax even further nobody knows for sure
but the mustache probably helped to
after 2 minutes in the water Brian
started having me signal with my finger
every few seconds to let him know I was
okay we'll say this again please never
attempt this without professional
supervision and before I knew it I'd
lasted three minutes and then 3 minutes
and 30 seconds then 3 minutes and 45
seconds
bring your feet
got your breath
no circle over 64 16 that's awesome for